we're later going to talk about what
might have landed president Trump in the
hospital for an unscheduled visit and
we're going to talk about many of the
things in fact which would likely have
caused stress over the weekend because
quite frankly it was a very stressful
couple of days for Donald Trump during
the second day of the impeachment
hearings on Friday with Murray
Jovanovic clothes stove Roger stone a
close Trump advisor Roger stone and
close Trump ally Roger stone was found
guilty on all seven counts with which he
was charged and Trump absolutely
exploded afterwards now as a reminder
please review my interview with Roger
stone from I guess it must be about a
year and a half ago at this point or
longer where Roger stone insisted he did
nothing wrong no one did anything wrong
and it turns out he may not have been
honest with me during that interview
check that out because Roger stone was
found guilty on seven counts including
lying to Congress witness tampering
obstruction of justice of the Russia
probe into Donald Trump he is Trump aide
and advisor number six to be convicted
so far so the immediate question is how
much time might Roger stone end up doing
in prison the answer on paper is that he
could end up with up to twenty years
although if I had to bet and I am NOT a
betting man I would bet that Roger stone
gets nothing close to twenty years and
then of course we will talk about pardon
possibilities momentarily adding to the
hijinks of the stone guilty verdict
there's this other Trump aide named
Michael Caputo who was in the courtroom
at the time of the verdicts read out and
he had to be removed from the courtroom
because when the verdict was read he
just turned around and turned his back
on the jury extraordinarily childish but
again these are the types of people that
Donald Trump has around him in a variety
of different capacities and then of
course Trump exploding on Twitter and
why wouldn't he if stone were to turn on
Trump it could be very very bad for the
president although there's no indication
at this point in time that stone plans
to turn on Trump for the purposes of a
lighter sentence
why would he if he expects or
anticipates that he will be pardoned by
Donald Trump but we will get to that
Trump first tweeting but but but but
what about all the people that I want
put in jail saying quote so they now
convict Roger stone of lying and want to
jail him for many years to come
well what about crooked Hillary Comey
struck Paige McKay Brennan clapper
shifty Schiff and Nellie Steele and all
of the others including even Muller
himself didn't they lie a double
standard like never seen before in the
history of our country understand that
the President of the United States is
publicly saying he wants to put the
legally appointed special counsel who
investigated him in prison Trump
believes on the one hand I guess that
Muller wrote a report that completely
exonerates him remember Trump went
around the country claiming that Robert
Muller completely exonerated him but
then he also wants the person who
supposedly exonerated him imprisoned
authoritarian on one hand but also a
completely incoherent on the other hand
and then of course you're still talking
about Hillary Donald
seriously and notably it's important
that Trump doesn't actually say in the
tweets stone is innocent stone is not
guilty stone might be innocent he merely
says if you convict Roger stone for this
then you should really convicted I don't
like it's brazen authoritarian what
about ISM now let's discuss the pardon
that's the other topic here that
deserves some attention although it
probably deserves that it's its own
exploration in a topic in and of itself
as usual the White House is not even
entertaining the idea that Donald Trump
may have signaled in any direct or even
indirect way that any pardons would be
incoming for anybody who keeps their
mouth shut now we do have when it kind
of came to Paul Manafort there were
allegations that the possibility of a
pardon had been intimated through a
number of different channels I don't
have anything
typically about Roger stone here but we
do know that if you keep your mouth shut
and you don't turn on Trump and you
don't turn into someone who could
potentially put Trump in a precarious
position you may be rewarded with a
pardon when it is all said and done I
hope that Robert Muller truly deeply
just sincerely regrets not subpoenaing
Donald Trump and at least trying to
force him to show up in person because
he didn't do it and Muller is still
getting crushed by Trump what was the
big advantage again to not bringing
Trump in I guess it was that Muller said
well the policy of the Justice
Department is not to prosecute sitting
presidents so we decided not even to
subpoena Donald Trump arguably the
weakest decision of Moeller's entire
investigation maybe of his entire career
because in the end he didn't do it he
let Trump off in in the weakest possible
way and Trump is still saying publicly
what about imprisoning Robert Muller
pardon we will see Roger stone
sentencing not scheduled until I believe
it's in the first week of February and
when that time comes we will see what
the guy ends up with I think it will be
far far short of the 20 year maximum
that he could hypothetically be
sentenced to let me know what you think
about the likely sentencing for Roger
stone